[Music]
robots angry sing your partner for
details and ham and the workplace
mix rally team blue sister plants
information of the thistle warmt
into the physics and microsoft we have in
working to bridge the gap between robots
and you want my lover ching sexuality
there is  special anchors is a mix yeti
cloud service the users computer vision to
localize device into the sting places in
the giant
exactly and got over time the special
anchor is kenny shady tree
android ios and had lens devices to
some graphics and diesel content
the the wheel world becomes  it here also
agents and common core nose is too wierik
site that two needle and we are going to fight
in this shirt
so you ankle we have a robot to
localize so ankle
drop winter sherry kings themselves tip
specially thought about mixed reality
girls and each other
who should care great great
time while accessing contacts and the
permission from other devices and form
xj-type customer service
in addition kr  oon application that mix
for yane who want off with many
impasse that way in my career
attraction we give in people insider
what cities intentions and the take
lingerie frank frank ind radiation
the robot something to offer calibri the
camera and these are protests vision
system in order  to create and christmas
special and chris freejam discriminant
roy specials longer
where we have a camera from the leica
this is a special be successful
so then no point u jekino for and
stage for more remove aswan wrapper
easy integration into your bike
spreadshirt please  follow the link here
for more information vs the game and
harding instead i think so special en
chris
york